going to a party where there are these
wonderful celebrity types resting you
don't like that no right so that is my
worst nightmare why is it your worst
nightmare because what you think it's
shallow fake it's just these like it's
people like doing an impression of
having a conversation so when I saw you
at the Met Gala read them paper you went
to that was that a miserable night whew
you're dressed up and you've got to sit
there and sort of feel on and talk to
everyone I left the I left not the
second I could I left earlier than I
should have been allowed but I mean it's
exciting you know it's like I got to
meet Beyonce right and she's like is
this your first Becca and I was like
it's my last but yet you're the same
woman who when you met j-law you you hit
it off with her though so there was
she's like - yeah she's yet I'm not
trying to make lots of celebrity friends
you're not the people that I care about
you have to I have to keep it so real
with them I can't be like yeah no we're
I I really like this girl like me and
Taylor Swift like we just hit it off and
it's and I don't know like I'm just I'm
part of that world now like they do like
get the [ __ ] out of here